es otra noche violenta en las calles de
colombia un oficial con graves
quemaduras y un joven fallecido en
cuentas de la inconformidad social en el
país sudamericano de díaz los
manifestantes dicen estar dispuesto a
quedarse en las calles hasta ser
escuchados ya sea movilizándose o
bloqueando algunas carreteras como no
hay fabricación no hay mano de obra
entonces no producen obviamente sea
desempleado unos dineros al estado
aunque estas manifestaciones son
apoyadas por la mayoría
muchos alertan del desabastecimiento que
los bloqueos podrían generar
pero la ayuda de todo el mundo no el
gobierno perdió este sábado al
negociador con los manifestantes miguel
ceballos que argumentó motivos
personales y es el tercero del gabinete
de iván duque que renuncia en el
contexto de las protestas que iniciaron
el 28 de abril en rechazo a un proyecto
de reforma tributaria pero luego se
transformaron a otras demandas sociales
pese al lento avance de las
negociaciones la orden presidencial
crear las vías y militarizar las
ciudades continúa provocando choques
violentos que ha dejado más de 50
fallecidos de los cuales 14 han sido por
brutalidad policial según organismos de
derechos humanos este lunes el ministro
de defensa diego molano comparece en el
senado por su responsabilidad sobre los
abusos policiales contra los
manifestantes
[Aplausos]